all right welcome back everybody
I guess the class is a little thin today
I heard there was a really bad car
accident in LAN North gates I five near
north gate but fortunately you can all
download this after class okay so what
we've been talking about our
differential equations X dot equals a
times X and I'm starting to feel a
little bit like we're ready to move on
from from X dot equals a X so today what
I'm going to do is I'm going to tell you
kind of the last piece of this puzzle
for linear differential equations okay
there's one type of a matrix that we
haven't analyzed yet and we're gonna
finish this last piece of the puzzle
today and then for the rest of the week
we're going to think about what would
happen when we add in some kind of
forcing some kind of a kind of an
external forcing so what good is a
differential equation if we can't
interact with it and actually modify the
solution to do something we want so in
the example of the pendulum we might
want to stabilize the inverted pendulum
to make a rocket ship you know be able
to go up stable e with its thrust at the
bottom for the spring mass we might be
able we might want to control a damped
oscillation and minimize the reaction at
certain frequencies and so having this
input F is going to give us the
flexibility to model how disturbances
enter the system and also how we would
control the system with external forcing
okay but that's going to be the next two
lectures on Wednesday and Friday and one
last thing I should mention the midterm
exam is going to come out on Monday next
week not Wednesday so this makes it even
better for Halloween drinking because
it's due on Wednesday next week not
Friday so in the morning before class I
will post the midterm on the website
you'll be able to download it and then
you'll have a fixed amount of time to
work on it so you'll be able to like
print it out
and then work on it from us you know
some start time to some end time between
Monday and Wednesday and then you'll
either turn it in and hand or email it
to the TAS and to me okay so it comes
out on Monday it's due on Wednesday okay
good so this next piece of the puzzle
I'm going to tell you about for X dot
equals ax is actually extremely
fascinating and this has really really
important implications for lots of
physical systems especially fluid
dynamic systems so what I'm going to
tell you about are nearly degenerate
systems a and what I mean by nearly
degenerate is that the eigenvectors of a
are nearly parallel okay so this seems
kind of innocuous but as my eigenvectors
of a become closer and closer to
parallel really interesting and funny
things can happen that's what I'm going
to show you today okay so this is also
very relevant for the homework so
homework three has one of these
degenerates a matrices so I'm going to
cook up another one that is similar
maybe I'll do this on the far board okay
so the a matrix that I'm going to look
at is minus point zero nine one zero
minus 0.01 okay so first things first
what are the eigenvalues of the system
okay minus 0.01 and minus 0.009 so first
what is the first thing you notice about
this system what can you say about about
this linear system of equations
definitely stable for all time for all
initial conditions any initial condition
I start with will go to 0 as time goes
to infinity what else can you say about
the system
the eigenvalues are super close right
there about you know they're really
really close to each other about ten
percent off okay but the system is
technically stable okay so what's the
next step when I solve a linear system
of equations like this right okay so
we're getting ready for the midterm I
want you all to be able to solve linear
systems like this the next thing you do
is you find the eigenvectors thank you
okay so I'm gonna look for eigenvector
one corresponding to lambda one and I do
that by taking a minus lambda one times
the identity and I find which vector c1
makes that equal to the zero vector
right pretty straightforward we're
looking for I ghen vectors that are
mapped to zero by this a minus lambda I
okay so a minus lambda times the
identity is just okay so a minus this
lambda times the identity is minus 0.009
plus 0.01 so that's point
0:01 the off diagonal terms don't change
at all and then this number and this
number cancel and I go to zero here so
this is a minus lambda times the
identity
okay so what types of eigen vectors x
and y would make this equal to 2 0 sorry
so let's try X is 1 and if X is 1 then
what does y have to be minus 1000 minus
0.001 okay so this is the eigenvector C
1 corresponding to lambda 1 we can do
the same thing C 2 is the solution of a
a minus lambda 2 times the identity
matrix times C 2 equals 0 0 again what
is a minus this lambda times the
identity just 0 1 0 minus 0.001 okay so
what would be an eigenvector of this
system
well okay so Y has to be equal to zero
because there's no X I can possibly make
that would cancel these write these
terms so Y has to be 0 and X can be
anything because both of those X's are
getting multiplied by zero so I'm just
gonna say that it's 1 0 ok so I have
these two eigen vectors we noticed that
our Augen values were super close to
each other what about our eigen vectors
really even closer I mean these are
almost exactly parallel right like they
both point in the c2 points in the 1 0
direction and c1 points in the 1.001
direction they're basically the exact
same direction they're almost exactly
parallel and when you have almost
exactly parallel Augen vectors of an a
matrix with similar eigen values so the
eigen values have to be similar you can
get very strange behavior for the
solutions of the system ok so we know
that this solution is stable right has
to be but what I'm going to show you in
MATLAB is that if I plot the x
coordinate the first coordinate of this
solution versus time and I give it some
initial condition it can actually grow
almost as if it's going unstable for
some time before it actually decays in a
stable damping extremely weird we've
never seen anything like this before for
all of the stable systems we've looked
at before for every initial condition
just get sucked towards the origin but
here initial conditions can actually
grow in some transient fashion and then
get pulled towards the origin this is
really weird ok and this is called
transient energy growth and it's
responsible for lots of funny things and
physical systems that I'm going to tell
you about ok are there questions
about this setup before I go to MATLAB
and kind of plot this solution a little
bit okay we have an a matrix with pretty
close to the same eigen values so almost
similar eigen values extremely parallel
eigen vectors and what we're going to
see is that we get this funny transient
energy growth okay
so first I'm just going to show you the
phenomenon in MATLAB and then we're
going to start to think about why this
could possibly be true local there you
go
okay I'm gonna do this two ways one way
I'm gonna do is just plot it in P plane
and the other way I'm gonna do it is
just to do OD e 45 and convince you that
the solution looks kind of like how I
described it okay so I'm just gonna make
a script it's a little easier and on the
midterm I will ask you to know some
basic MATLAB okay like I might ask you
to write down on pencil and paper like
how to integrate a linear system using
OD 45 or I might ask you to make a plot
and show me your three lines of code or
something like that because this is
something we've done a lot of times in
class okay so we're gonna test what I'm
calling a non normal system okay so the
a matrix is negative 0.09 one zero
negative 0.01 that's my system I'm going
to integrate from time equals zero in
increments of 0.1 to a thousand and I'm
gonna start with an initial condition of
zero one okay so it's a little fuzzy
it's a little hard to see I apologize
okay so how do i do OD 45 to get the
solution of this what are the three
arguments that I need to give OD 45 so I
give it some right-hand side of the
differential equation
so for now I'll just okay and the
outputs are time and two column vectors
for y equals ode45 okay so I'm gonna
give it some some right-hand side okay
so I'm going to tell it it's a function
of T and Y and it's a times y that's
just my linear system is y dot equals a
times y I'm gonna integrate it for this
time span that I've defined so T equals
zero in increments of 0.1 to a thousand
and I'm going to start with an initial
condition of why not okay so I integrate
that and now I'm gonna plot my time
versus the first column of Y right
that's so I have this two-dimensional
system I have kind of X 1 and X 2 my
first column is the x1 coordinates and
we get this funny non kind of I'm if not
it's totally linear but there's this
transient growth before the system
eventually becomes stable and goes to
zero this is really weird we don't know
why this should happen yet okay
also the units of this are huge right it
goes up to about 40 before it decays but
my initial condition was 0 1 so I get a
40 times amplification of my initial
condition before it actually goes stable
this is very weird okay now I told you
that this was because we have parallel
eigenvectors of the a matrix are nearly
parallel so I should be able to see this
if I run P plane okay so now I'm in P
plane I'm just going to enter my linear
system which is minus point
okay so X dot is minus 0.09 times X plus
y and y dot is minus 0.01 times y
okay and I'm gonna make my display
window a little bit large negative 5 to
5 okay so if you download P plane and
see it you can see that there are these
little grey arrows which tell you which
direction the vector field goes and so
if I go near the origin and I click some
initial condition you can see what the
trajectory does is that all of the
arrows are pointing really really
strongly to the right and so my initial
condition goes to the right for a long
way before it eventually turns around
and comes back to the origin very very
strange okay so it's only pointing in
very near the origin let's try it
another solution so this red curve is
going way out maybe it'll like positive
20 before it turns around and comes back
in negative solutions do the same thing
and so you can see that this huge
excursion in the X Direction is that
transient growth that we see okay we
don't know why this this is happening it
we're gonna derive derive this but what
I'm trying to show you here is if I
integrate this system I have a huge
transient growth in some of the
variables before it becomes stable okay
yeah in one direction and then it goes
to zero but it want to be plane it went
one side of there
to the other as well right so P plane is
showing me X 1 versus X 2 it's not
showing the X versus time this is X 1
versus time so remember when I started
with that initial condition of P plane
went way for in the X 1 direction and
then came back that's this it went way
for in the X 1 direction and then it
comes back if I plotted the X 2
direction here so I'll say hold on plot
T y : 2 in red the red direction is
actually just doing a stable decay it's
acting totally normal okay
and that's what we saw in P plane so in
P plane I went way far in X 1 and then
came back but in X 2 I'm actually just
moving straight towards the origin I'm
decaying towards the origin in the in
the vertical direction okay so now we're
going to figure out why this is
happening
okay so to see why this is happening
what I'm going to do I cook the system
up because this happens very often in
real physical systems where you have
nearly identical eigenvalues and nearly
parallel eigenvectors what I'm going to
do now is actually show you the case
when the eigenvectors are exactly
parallel and when the eigenvalues are
exactly zero because this is easier to
solve okay so this is the case that
we're looking at now okay we have
exactly equal eigenvalues lambda and so
we're going to try to find what is you
know x of T X at time T is going to be e
to the a matrix times time x that's not
right this is always true for linear
systems always except for this type of a
matrix where you have repeated
eigenvalues and a one kind of off
diagonal I can't diagonalize it this is
as close to diagonal as I can possibly
make this matrix okay there's like a
whole bunch of linear algebra that
explains why I can't diagonal diagonal
eyes this and if you want to know more
about it you can look up the Jordan
canonical form it's quite fascinating
how many of you have heard of the Jordan
canonical form before okay this is
pretty good stuff so there's a lot of
good books you can find it in like this
book like Perko but this is really kind
of beyond what I want to do in this
class this is what you would get in a
dynamical systems class of finding what
all of these canonical forms are when
you can't perfectly diagonalize a system
this is the only case that you couldn't
diagonalize is when you have repeated
eigenvalues with parallel eigenvectors
okay so what I'm going to do first is
what I want to do is I want to split
this a matrix into two parts the
diagonal part and the off diagonal part
and I'm gonna call this s and this T
okay now remember if I have e to the
number s plus number T that's equal to e
to the S times e to the T right but this
is not true with matrices in general
in general each of the big s plus Big T
is not equal to e to the big s e to the
big T it's funny you can try it like
it's just does it's not true okay you
can try it in MATLAB like do the matrix
exponential but e to the big matrix s
plus T is equal to e to the S e to the T
if s times T equals T times s okay this
has a name in mathematics it's so
important this is called commuting so if
the matrix s times T is equal to the
matrix T times s then s and T are
commutative they commute with each other
you can swap their order and the
equations don't change okay this is not
true for all matrices if you just pick
two matrices out of a hat they will not
be commutative I guarantee it okay if
you randomly pick two matrices they will
not commute only very special matrices
will commute with each other okay this
is really really important in quantum
mechanics communitive matrices so this
is a theorem you could prove if you
wanted to you could prove this I don't
want to prove this
if you did want to prove it you would
use the binomial theorem and you would
say matrix s plus T to the K power let's
say to the nth power is equal to n
factorial sum of J plus K equals n of
the matrix S to the J T to the K over J
factorial K factorial if you wanted to
prove this theorem you would take this
binomial expansion and you plug it into
the Taylor series of e to the S Plus T
and it would separate into two Taylor
series of e to the s times e to the T I
don't want to do it this is not like a
pure math class we're not going to prove
things but you could prove this theorem
with this binomial expansion if you
wanted to okay but the point is that I
can take my a matrix and I can split it
into the diagonal matrix and this off
diagonal matrix S and T and it turns out
that these matrices do commute with each
other s times T does equal T times s for
this very special set of matrices and we
can just verify it right s times T is 0
0 lambda 0 0 0 lambda 0 and that's
exactly what I get if I switch the order
and multiply I get 0 0 lambda 0 so that
equals T times s ok these matrices do
commute and so the nice thing is is that
e to the matrix a t is equal to e to the
matrix s times time times e to the
matrix T times time this is true because
s and T have this special property that
they commute so it not be true otherwise
ok who's with me so far
I didn't prove
I didn't prove that this is true but
we're just using this fact that we can
split a into S&T they commute and so I
can write e to the S Plus T as e to the
S times e to the T ok now we know how to
solve eetu the diagonal matrix right so
what is that first one
what's each of the F plus T or s times
to you yeah e to the lambda T's on the
diagonal and zeros elsewhere right but
how do I solve this e to the matrix T
times time this is the last piece of the
puzzle here what do I do for eetu the
this matrix T
what do we do if we don't know how to
solve a system either the matrix times
time well so we could try to diagonalize
it but this is exactly the form lambda
lambda 1 so I'm telling you that we
can't diagonalize this one will get
stuck in an infinite loop trying we can
always go back to the first principles
in the first few lectures how did we
derive the solution e to the 8th e
Taylor series so let's think about the
Taylor series for e to the T so e to the
matrix T time is going to equal what's
what's the Taylor series for this
identity matrix plus plus T times time
plus 1/2 big matrix T squared times x
squared plus dot dot dot dot dot ok but
T squared is equal to 0 and T cubed is
equal to 0 and XI to the fourth is equal
to 0 and all powers of T above T to the
1 are equal to 0 that's always true of
these kind of off diagonal 5 zeros on
the diagonal and I have ones above it
then I can take powers of T and
eventually it will become 0 so all of
this is equal to 0 and each of this
matrix T times time is just the identity
matrix plus T times time really simple
matrix that's e to the T times time
identity matrix plus T times time
okay any questions at this point there's
a lot of sex this is a big recipe
okay so we're cooking something nice
here but it takes a lot of steps and we
have to remember what stuff we're in
okay we have this a matrix with repeated
eigenvalues we can split it into s and T
and I'm telling you that because of some
special fact of those matrices the
solution e to the a times time is e to
the s time times e to the T time and now
we know it e to the T is 1 T 0 1 and so
the full solution to this equation is e
to the lambda T now T e to the lambda T
that's interesting 0 and e to the lambda
T ok this is pretty cool so we're going
to box this this is the solution and
notice that we get this new term that
we've never seen before we had this T e
to the lambda t we've never seen this
term before in linear systems of
equations at least not in this class so
this is an entirely new term and there
are sometimes called secular terms don't
ask me why
curious why actually I want to know but
I don't and if I plot T e to the lambda
T it looks like that transient growth
that we saw okay so T and e to the
lambda T are competing with each other
e to the lambda T is trying to damp
everything out but T is getting bigger
and bigger and bigger and for a little
while it's actually getting bigger
faster than either the lambda
she is getting smaller and so for the
first part of this transient growth the
T term is winning until then the e to
the mighty to the lambda T term starts
to dominate so the transient growth that
we saw is entirely due to these kind of
secular terms these t e to the lambda T
terms now for this kind of system you
exactly have these terms in the system I
showed you in the first example where
the eigenvectors were only you know the
eigenvalues were only close to each
other and the eigenvectors were nearly
parallel it's getting closer and closer
to this canonical form okay questions
so when the system is unstable even
lambda t is trying to blow up and t is
trying to blow up so they just both blow
up but it will blow up faster slightly
faster than just e to the plus T so this
is only really seen for stable
eigenvalues yeah that's a really good
point so you'll only notice this for
stable lambda for lambda with negative
real part okay and we can plot this in
MATLAB let's just do it really quickly
it's weird okay
so what I'm just gonna do is make a T
vector zero in increments of 0.01 to 20
and I'm gonna plot T by T times e to the
minus T okay so notice that I'm doing T
dot x why do I have a dot x in here
right because these are both vectors T
is a vector and each of the minus T is
also a vector and so dot times is going
to multiply them element wise and I'll
get each element in a new vector okay
and so when I plot this I get my nice
beautiful transient growth in that
coordinate that we saw before and this
is purely because of that extra secular
term T e to the minus lambda T okay so
I'm just convincing you that that's
exactly what this term looks like is
transient growth before an eventual
decay okay good
okay now a couple other things I want to
show you yeah so I literally just drew
this one term but the X so X 1 is going
to equal some linear combination of
these things and so the X 1 coordinate
is going to have this secular term but
the X 2 is not which is why when we
plotted in this case the X 1 term had
that big transient growth but the X 2
term was just decaying to the origin
okay the homework problem I flipped it
so the X 2 direction will have the
transient growth and the X 1 will be
attracting to the origin it's a little
more physical if you think of V is a
velocity the second component is the
velocity it's a little more physical
okay so this is actually good we're
getting very close to being done with e
to the H e because this is the last
piece of the puzzle
so it turns out that you can have other
even worse secular terms if I have I
could have an a matrix that is like
lambda lambda lambda 1 1 0 I think I
need to watch Revenge of the Nerds again
okay and you can get an e to the 80 so
notice here now I have a triplicate
lambda and I have two ones on the off
tag and also this is even worse then
this e to the 80 is going to be e to the
lambda T's on the diagonal just like
before
zero zero zero and just like before I'm
gonna have my first order secular term T
e to the lambda T te to the lambda T but
up here in the upper right I'm actually
gonna get a 1/2 T squared e to the
lambda T so I can get second order
secular terms if I had a quadruple
eigenvalue I could get T to the third e
to the lambda T's if I had Quinn tipple
eigenvalues I could have T to the fourth
e to the lambda T's I can get
arbitrarily many of these e to the
lambda T's and something interesting
that happens when you have these so if I
have like let's say I have a T to the
fifth either lambda T or e to the lambda
T of stable
okay I'm gonna draw this one in black
and I'm gonna draw T e to the lambda T
in red so remember our original
transient energy growth was just like
that
but if I have like a fifth order secular
term because maybe I had six repeated
eigenvalues then it's actually going to
look more like that so the peak is going
to move to the right in time so the peak
is going to be delayed in time which is
a weird phenomenon but we see this in
lots of systems so if you see something
that grows really slowly to a huge value
then comes back down and it comes back
down quickly then this is probably a
high order secular term okay this is
just something you should know
okay good
okay so we had we've seen two different
types of a matrices with repeated
eigenvalues and they have very different
behavior so I want to look at these two
different a matrices call it a tail of
two a matrices in the first case we've
seen a equals 1 0 1 0 or sorry 1 0 0 1
the diagonal matrix the identity this a
has repeated eigenvalues lambda 1 equals
1 lambda 2 equals 1 we know what the
solution of the system is right yeah
it's just either the T 0 0 e to the T
all right simple its diagonal we know
how to solve this system ok and what we
could do is we could try to compute the
eigen vectors of this a matrix so how
would we do that
I would say well a minus lambda times
the identity times C equals the 0 vector
right but a minus lambda times the
identity is just identity minus identity
it's 0 0 0 0 times you know x and y
equals 0 0 so what are some possible
eigen vectors what are some possible X&Y
that make this true all x and y right
all x and y make this true so I can have
C 1 equals just the X vector and C 2
equals the Y vector I can just pick them
to be orthogonal because a minus lambda
I is completely rank deficient it has
rank 0 meaning all vectors in the plane
will map to 0
okay and what this means is that I have
two unique eigenvectors for that
eigenvalue lambda I have two completely
unique eigenvectors because I have to
hold erections that map to zero by this
matrix so remember before we were
looking for the determinant of a minus
lambda I 2 equals 0 to find eigenvalues
now we have to look at the rank so the
rank of a minus lambda I here is 0 has 0
rank okay so I have two degrees of
freedom that will map to the 0 vector I
have the X direction and the y direction
and that's why this a matrix is easy in
some sense because I have two orthogonal
eigen vectors okay let's look at the
second case that we did today I equals 1
1 0 1 again identical eigen values
lambda 1 equals 1 lambda 2 equals 1 we
now know what the solution is it's e to
the a T equals e to the T T e to the T 0
e to the T ok but it's a little bit more
complicated when I can try to compute
the eigen vector of this I say a minus
lambda identity times C equals 0 what's
a minus lambda times the identity
well it's just a minus the identity
because lambda is 1 so I get 0 1 0 0 so
what do we notice right off the bat with
this eigenvector equation
well I mean first thing I noticed that I
could write an eigenvector 1 zero right
Y has to be 0 because I have nothing to
cancel this term X can be anything but
the other thing I noticed is that this
matrix has rank 1 and so there's only
one eigenvector direction that maps to 0
before I had this kind of 0 rank a minus
lambda I matrix so both the X and the y
directions map to 0 but here a minus
lambda I only has Rank 1 it's only so a
has rank two okay and so this only is
one lower than this which means that it
only Maps one direction to zero and I
only have one eigen vector corresponding
to that eigenvalue it's really weird
ok to find more what are called
generalized eigenvectors we have to
solve a minus lambda i squared times c2
equals zero zero okay so how many of you
remember generalized eigenvectors from
linear algebra you know it doesn't get
talked about that often I almost brushed
it onto the rug I wanted to but it's
really important to tell you a little
bit more about what's going on here when
you have repeated eigenvalues when you
have repeated eigenvalues and a minus
lambda I is that many eigenvalues lower
rank than a then I get two or however
many unique eigenvector directions okay
if I had three eigenvalues then I would
want this rank I would still want this
to be zero and then I would have three
unique eigenvector directions and my
system would be simple diagonal
okay in this case I have a rank two
system and I have a multiplicity two
eigenvalue I have a eigenvalue that's
repeated twice but a minus lambda I only
has rank one so there's only one
eigenvector for that eigenvalue unless I
start solving for these generalized
eigenvectors okay so in this case
essentially this is geometrically what's
different between these two cases in one
of the cases a minus lambda I has a
lower rank than in the other case so I
need to introduce new eigenvectors here
that's as much as i want to talk about
generalized eigenvectors and jordan
canonical forms if you were taking a
whole class on linear algebra and
differential equations then we would go
more into depth about how to compute all
of these eigenvectors and what they mean
physically but for now if you have a
system like this you have to get these
extra t e to the lambda T terms okay and
they give you transient energy growth
okay any questions before I move on I
got a few more minutes so I could talk
more about math or I could talk a little
bit about physics I still want to talk
to you about physics right now
okay
so these types of a matrices a equals 1
1 0 1 are called non normal non normal
means that does not satisfy a transpose
times a equals a a transpose ok if this
equation was true then a would be called
a normal matrix and it would definitely
have unique eigenvectors for every
single multiple Lygon value and this
comes up a lot in fluid flows okay so if
I have a shear flow where I have lower
velocity on the bottom and then it gets
faster and faster and faster so so
partial u velocity with respect to Y is
some constant this comes up all the time
if I have a boundary layer flow so I
have flow going past a wing then often
what I'll have is some kind of a laminar
flow and then eventually it'll become
turbulent
but in this laminar region the velocity
profile looks like a shear flow looks
like that ok and if I take this a matrix
and I multiply a little unit cube you'll
see what I mean by here I mean these
guys were really creative when they
named these it literally looks like a
pair of shears let's see if I can draw
this
okay
so if I take this unit Q but I map it
through a this box shears looks like a
pair of shears okay it's a shear flow
and what we find is that in the laminar
fluid regime the system is stable okay
meaning that if I kicked the flow a
little bit if I added a little burst of
air or a little tornado that little
tornado or bursts of error it's going to
convict downstream but it's going to
damp out and die okay the flow is trying
to maintain this laminar solution it's
going to kill all disturbances except in
these shear flows what happens is if I
have some disturbance in time or in the
x coordinate they're basically the same
thing because everything is moving from
left to right that disturbance might
initially grow before it then decays
right because I have this non normal a
matrix initially even though all
disturbances are eventually going to die
out in this laminar region first they
might grow in magnitude like 40 or 50 or
even a thousand times their original
magnitude before they die out so this
little tornado might actually get super
strong before it then dies out okay and
what's interesting is that because we're
talking about a fluid flow it's not just
a linear system there's also a
non-linearity so it's you know X dot
equals some matrix plus some nonlinear
function of X and so there's some
turbulent threshold so that even if I'm
in the linear stable regime where
transient disturbances should die out
they should be stable if my disturbance
grows large enough then it'll actually
start to excite on
and the solution will go chaotic and
turbulence this is a really weird
phenomenon people had observed this in
fluid flows for decades systems where
they knew that it was linearly stable
but disturbances would keep growing and
growing and growing and then tripped the
system into a turbulent flow so a pipe
is a great example of this a pipe is
linearly stable for all flow velocities
if you have flow going through a pipe it
should be stable for all flow velocities
if you look at the partial differential
equation any amount of roughness in the
wall creates disturbances and those
disturbances grow until they excite
nonlinearities and trip the pipe into
turbulent flow so if you polished your
pipe low enough I have a friend I swear
to god he polished a pipe for two weeks
and he got the most laminar flow in a
pipe that's ever been recorded because
all turbulence and pipes come from wall
roughness and disturbances he was a
great polisher of pipes and he has one
of the best papers and high Reynolds
number fluid flows like in existence
today because he was able to keep these
disturbances small so that they didn't
transiently grow and excite
nonlinearities hate not all of your
fluid mechanician x' but everybody loves
pretty pictures so I'm just going to
show you a couple of videos of this
until the bell rings
okay let's see if I can find a turbulent
boundary layer
so this is a direct numerical simulation
of a turbulent boundary layer this is
what's happening over your airplane wing
and these disturbances are moving down
the plates something Bad's happening
they're moving down the plate and you
can see these turbulent structures
coming in and out of the plane they're
getting amplified so these are the kinds
of nonlinear turbulent flow features
that are being amplified and you can
trip an otherwise stable flow into this
nasty turbulent regime if you give it a
large enough disturbance and if that
disturbance is aligned in the flow
direction so that it has non normal
energy growth okay that's all for today
next time we're gonna add forcing two
differential equations
you